jetzt rufe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 8 erste beratung des
von den fraktionen spd bündnis 90 die
grünen und der fdp eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zur änderung des
stabilisierungs fonds und des
wirtschafts stabilisierungs
beschleunigungsgesetz es für diese
aussprache ist eine dauer von 31 minuten
beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und das wort
hat der kollege otto fricke von der fdp
fraktion
er schätzte frau präsidentin auch wenn
ich jetzt denke warum gehen die alle
wenn ich mit der rede anfange möchte ich
doch als aller erstes mal hervorheben
dass wir jetzt hier einen gesetzentwurf
haben den ich gemeinsam mit den kollegen
sven-christian kindler und dennis rohde
vorbereiten durfte und da will ich
zeigen wie diese neue ampelkoalition
auch da schon gearbeitet hat als der
bundeskanzler noch gar nicht gewählt war
ich möchte ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen
wir haben in den nächsten monaten neben
all den aufgaben die der
koalitionsvertrag an uns heran trägt
eine ganz wesentliche überlegungen zu
treffen wie stabilisieren wir unsere
wirtschaft wie stabilisieren wir unsere
sozialsysteme wie stabilisieren wir
insbesondere die betroffenen unternehmen
in der nächsten zeit in der phase wo wir
noch nicht genau wissen wie es mit
gewohnt weitergeht dementsprechend legt
ihnen die koalition einen gesetzentwurf
vor der eines der elemente neben der
frage kurzarbeit überbrückung ganz
essentiell für deutsche unternehmen ist
es sind die beiden gesetze die sich
beziehen auf den stabilisierungsfonds
und es sind wieder ja sehr schön an der
anzeige noch sehen dass wirtschaft staat
diese jungs beschleunigungsgesetz beiden
gesetzen geht es letztlich darum wie wir
größeren unternehmen aber auch
mittelständischen unternehmen helfen
wenn sie in liquiditätsschwierigkeiten
kommen eigentlich sollten diese gesetze
auslaufen zum ende des jahres das hätte
bedeutet
es hätten keine weiteren anträge mehr
bearbeitet werden können das hätte
bedeutet es wäre an der stelle auch mit
weiteren helfen trotz der
notwendigkeiten die uns corinna da
erzwingt nicht mehr so erfolgt hätten
können wie es bedarf der bedarf gewesen
wäre die koalition ist zu dem ergebnis
gekommen ich danke dann nochmal den
kollegen dass wir gesagt haben ja wir
verlängern aber wir verlängern nicht ad
infinitum sondern wir sagen ganz klar
wir müssen aus dieser situation dann
irgendwann auch rauskommen der
gesetzentwurf sieht vor dass wir zum
ende des monates juno die möglichen
hilfen aus diesem fonds dann beenden
werden das bedeutet ab dann wird es
keine neuen beschlüsse mehr geben
gleichzeitig beheben wir aber auch einen
konstruktionsfehler des alten gesetzes
nämlich dass die antragsfristen quasi
noch bis zum ende des gesetzentwurfes
gehen das gibt allen beteiligten
unternehmen seien sie klein seien sie
groß ich nehme hier nur das beispiel
lufthansa die möglichkeit hilfen vom
staat dann zu bekommen wenn sie in ihrer
liquidität gefährdet sind zweitens und
das ist ganz wichtig machen wir aber
auch etwas was für meine fraktion von
ganz besonderer bedeutung ist und das
ist auch ein signal an die kapitalmärkte
wir haben in der bisherigen form durch
die große koalition ein volumen von
achtung 600 milliarden euro gehabt die
nach außen gestellt wurden diese 600
milliarden euro waren ein
sicherheitspuffer was sich der alten
regierung auch durchaus zu billige dass
er richtig war aber er war zu hoch weil
und das möchte ich deutlich sagen es
erkennbar nicht notwendig war so viel zu
helfen wir haben etwa im bereich der
unternehmenshilfen von den bis zu 100
milliarden die wir an geboten haben
maximal acht milliarden genutzt das
reduzieren wir jetzt wir brauchen nicht
diese 100 milliarden sondern wir geben
dem kapitalmarkt begeben denjenigen die
auch in zukunft deutschland hilfen geben
werden am kapitalmarkt wie unsere bonds
zeichnen werden ein deutliches signal
und reduzieren das von 100 milliarden
auf 50 milliarden und bevor jetzt hier
kritik kommt
bevor jetzt hier kritik kommt das ist
immer noch das zehnfache dessen was
bisher in anspruch genommen wurde und
damit ausreichend bei den ausgestellten
garantien gehen wir von 400 milliarden
zurück auf 100 milliarden weil diese
garantien bisher nicht genutzt worden
auch das ist ein zeichen und das ist
doch wichtig ich will dabei und das
möchte ich zum schluss meiner rede dann
noch deutlich hervorheben den
zusammenhang mit dem was auch in der
nächsten woche noch auf uns zukommt
stellen und das ist die frage wie wir im
haushalt insgesamt stehen wir werden
weil die wirtschaftliche entwicklung so
ist wie sie ist wir werden auch deswegen
weil wir einen umbau und das sage ich
jetzt besonders in richtung meiner neuen
freunde von den grünen weil wir beim
thema nachhaltigkeit einen erheblichen
umbau unserer industrie brauchen werden
wir sehr viel haushaltsmittel auch
benötigen dafür muss dafür muss der
bundeshaushalt die entsprechenden
volumina haben und deswegen glaube ich
zeigen dir mit diesem gesetzentwurf auch
sehr deutlich dass die flexibilität des
haushaltes gegeben ist die ausreichenden
mittel zur verfügung stehen meine damen
und herren zum schluss
heute reden wir darüber wie wir helfen
wie wir stabilisieren aber wir müssen
auch ganz klar erkennen wir werden bei
maßnahmen und da richte ich mich auch
richtige richtung arbeits und
sozialministerium aber auch richtung
wirtschaftsministerium sehr genau gucken
wie wir in den nächsten monaten aus der
situation corona heraus gleiten denn wir
können diese hilfssysteme nicht
dauerhaft machen wir müssen herauskommen
aus einer stagnation und deswegen
schließe ich auch für den kollegen rohde
weil ich nicht immer shakespeare oder
goethe zitieren will mit herrn brandt
willy brandt regierungserklärung 1969
unser ziel lautet stabilisierung ohne
stagnation herzlichen dank und du fricke
war das haushaltspolitiker der fdp und
ein bisschen müssen wir noch an uns an
die neuen rollen gewöhnen otto fricke
jetzt also für die regierungskoalition
und als nächster redner kommt andreas
jung viele jahre in den kohl in der
koalitions fraktionen der union jetzt
opposition
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen als union stehen wir kritisch
in opposition zu dieser regierung aber
wir arbeiten für die menschen in unserem
land und deshalb werden wir vorlagen
nicht daran bemessen wo sie herkommen
sondern daran was drin steht und deshalb
will ich kollege fritz ich sagen dass
ich die überlegungen die sie eben
vorgetragen haben im grundsatz
nachvollziehen kann das ist auch die
haltung meiner fraktion wir sind der
meinung dass es richtig ist über eine
verlängerung der fristen wie sie es
dargestellt haben zu sprechen nicht
dauerhaft aber solange die krise geht
und wir halten es für richtig garantie
rahmen auch runterzufahren für uns gilt
ein versprechen wir haben zugesagt in
dieser situation in der unser land hart
getroffen ist schon der pandemie in der
auch die wirtschaftliche tätigkeit hat
betroffen sind in der unternehmen in
ihrer existenz gefährdet sind und in der
es um arbeitsplätze geht da werden wir
alles tun um diese arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und dieses versprechen das gilt
auch in der opposition und deshalb
werden wir in konstruktivem geist die
diskussion über dieses gesetz führen
aber
ich sage ihnen auch dazu es geht auch
ein anderes versprechen wir haben hier
im deutschen bundestag das versprechen
abgegeben wenn wir jetzt so betroffen
sind wenn wir von der ausnahmeregelung
der schuldenbremse gebrauch machen
müssen und viele milliarden schulden
aufnehmen müssen um in dieser situation
zu stabilisieren
dann werden wir diese schulden in
unserer generation
zurückbezahlen das haben wir hier im
deutschen bundestag
beschlossen gemeinsam und ich fordere
den bundeskanzler auf das versprechen
das er als bundesfinanzminister gegeben
hat nicht zu brechen das haben sie aber
vor in ihrem koalitionsvertrag sie
wollen nicht in den nächsten 20 jahren
die schulden zurückbezahlen sie wollen
sie es um 16 jahre um die zukunft
verschieben das entspricht nicht ihrem
selbst formulierten anspruch ein bündnis
für nachhaltigkeit zu sein das ist
politik zu lasten der künftigen
generation und ist es brechen das von
uns gemeinsam gegebenen versprechens bei
der ersten gelegenheit mit einem
federstrich das werden der ihnen nicht
durchgehen lassen und dasselbe gilt im
übrigen bei dem was sie in der
haushaltspolitiker otto fricke
angesprochen ganz generell sei das
schreiben sie die schuldenbremse für
nach der krise ab 223 in den
koalitionsvertrag und dann sucht man das
finanztableau stellt fest fehlanzeige
man sucht die priorisierung für
zukunftsinvestitionen und stellt fest
fehlanzeige und stattdessen wollen sie
haushalt tricks machen sie wollen
schattenhaushalte aufmachen die
haushalts grundsätze aber heißen
klarheit und wahrheit und nicht schatten
und nebel wir werden ihm das nicht
durchgehen lassen wir werden auf
transparenz dringen wir werden auf eine
solide haushaltspolitik inszenierter
künftigen generationen auch in zukunft
hier in diesem hause trinken herzlichen
dank an reaktion war das für die
unionsfraktion und er hat ein wie ich
finde guten satz gesagt nämlich vorlagen
wollen wir nicht danach bewerten woher
sie kommen sondern danach was drinsteht
nächster redner in dieser debatte in der
es um die fortschreibung von
wirtschaftshilfen geht bis in das
nächste jahr hinein ist andreas schwartz
aus der spd-fraktion werte präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
lieben mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger an
den fernsehbildschirmen
es ist mir eine außerordentliche freude
nach der gestrigen wahl von unserem
neuen bundeskanzler olaf scholz heute
einen brachte den ersten gesetzentwurf
der neuen bundesregierung vorstellen zu
dürfen und ich darf an der stelle auch
nochmals alles gute der neuen
bundesregierung wünschen glücklich ist
und gutes händchen aber natürlich auch
den neuen hier im bundestag dass es uns
gelingt gemeinsam für dieses land gute
entscheidungen zu treffen so wie wir
hier gerade den einstieg in gute neue
entscheidungen wagen weil wir werden
heute in erster lesung darüber beraten
ein gesetz zu verlängern das bis 31 12
gelten sollte oder geht es um
stabilisierungsmaßnahmen des wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds auch kurz dsf
genannt dh wir wollen die gegen platz
sichern und zukunft und fortschritt
gestalten zu können leider meine damen
und herren ist corona nicht vorbei und
weiterhin ist entschlossenes handeln so
wie das in der vorgängerregierung
gemacht haben auch jetzt in der
ampelkoalition
notwendig und natürlich sind auch die
länder wichtig bei dem weg den wir jetzt
hier gemeinsam gehen es geht hier nicht
nur wie das im täglichen leben erleben
dürfen um einschränkungen die wir eben
durchmachen müssen wir müssen abstand
halten wir müssen uns den masten zwang
auch hier im hause unter wasser ist auch
richtig und ist auch wichtig war auch
gesundheitsschutz eine wichtige maßnahme
ist aber meine damen und herren was
erwarten die unternehmerinnen
unternehmer in unserem land von der
politik in dieser zeit sie erwarten
kontinuität bei den entscheidungen zu
erwarten verlässlichkeit auf einen
starken start den wir gott sei dank
haben und sie erwarten stelle mutige
entscheidungen und reaktionen das heißt
sie erwarten rettungsschirme die wenn
notwendig auch gewährleisten dass sie
hält unternehmen brauchen am ende des
tages planbarkeit und dafür sorgt diese
bundesregierung
die stabilisierungsmaßnahmen des
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds zeigen
das land steht zusammen auch in
schwierigen zeiten und die unternehmen
können sie auf unserem staat verlassen
das zeigen nicht nur die
wirtschaftsdaten das zeigt auch der
arbeitsmarkt wo wir auch sehr
stabilisierend eingegriffen haben denn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bei den
betroffenen unternehmen geht es häufig
auch um viele tausende von
arbeitsplätzen die gefährdet sind hier
haben wir nicht nur eine
arbeitspolitischen auch eine
industriepolitische verantwortung die
wir mit sicherheit sehr ernst nehmen es
geht auch um schlüsseltechnologien die
wir vor dem ausverkauf sichern müssen
aber es geht wie gesagt auch um viele
arbeitsplätze die wir halten wollen
deswegen werden wir diesen
gesetzesentwurf bis 30 juni
2022 verlängern würden wir nicht
verlängern dann wäre dies meine damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen
nach derzeitiger lage ein völlig
falsches signal nach draußen wirtschaft
hat auch viel mit psychologie zu tun wir
müssen weiter in der lage sein die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der krone
pandemie für betroffene unternehmen
abzufedern liebe mitbürger mitbürger
gerade mit dem wsf haben die
bundesregierung und die als parlament im
märz 2020 ein ganz ganz wichtiges signal
und instrument geschaffen um größeren
unternehmen die in notlage geraten sind
helfen zu können sie erinnern sich und
es wurde schon erwähnt hat die
problematik der lufthansa der wwf ist
aber kein hexenwerk aber wird wunder und
besteht wie sieht es nun aus drei
elementen mit einem bisherigen
gesamtvolumen von 600 milliarden euro
dabei wollen wir jetzt den
garantierahmen von 400 milliarden euro
reduzieren weil er bisher auch nicht in
anspruch genommen wurde das zeigt wir
haben nicht nur stabile staatsfinanzen
stabiles bankenwesen wir haben auch
robuste unternehmen deshalb passen wir
den rahmen auf 100 milliarden euro
zukünftig an darüber hinaus gibt es drei
kapitals rekapitalisierungsmaßnahmen die
bis zum direkten einstieg des staates in
unternehmen ja gegriffen haben auch hier
wollen wir die obergrenze kappen von 500
milliarden wie bereits erwähnt von
kollegen otto fricke auf 50 milliarden
nach bisherigen berechnungen wurden ja
auch nur 8,8 milliarden euro davon in
anspruch genommen keine änderung meine
damen und herren wird es bei der
finanzierung von corona sonderprogrammen
über die kfw geben die hatten bisher 100
milliarden und sollen die auch weiterhin
behalten obwohl auch da im moment als 35
4 milliarden ausgereicht wurden sie
sehen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds ist in
diesen schwierigen zeiten wichtig und er
ist eine absolute erfolgsstory und es
ist mehr als sinnvoll in auch
weiterzuführen meine damen und herren
liebe zuschauerinnen zuschauer eine
bildschirmen die botschaft lautet wir
bewahren das land und unsere wirtschaft
vor erheblichen beschädigungen und
stabilisieren den arbeitsmarkt das nenne
ich voraussicht und passte das motto
unserer neuen regierung mehr fortschritt
wagen weil wir es können vielen dank
andreas schwartz war das aus der
spd-fraktion zum
stabilisierungsfonds gesetz dasein
fristen verlängert werden damit
wirtschaftshilfen auch noch bis in den
nächsten juni hinein fließen können
hintergrund ist natürlich die
pandemische situation die er nach wie
vor haben als nächster redner ist peter
böhringer dran war in der letzten
legislaturperiode vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses in dieser
legislaturperiode wird die af den drei
ausschüsse anführen nämlich in
gesundheit und wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und das hat heftige
diskussionen ausgelöst
kronen garantie volumens von über 500
milliarden euro ist überfällig wir haben
sie eben gehört es war je nach rechnung
um 500 bis 900 oder 1000 prozent zu hoch
angesetzt von olaf scholz das ist davon
reden wir hier das wird ja jetzt mal
korrigiert profitiert haben aber vom
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds
entgegen dem was wir eben gehört haben
fast nur nach politischen kriterien
ausgesuchte großunternehmen jeder
arbeitsplatz etwa bei der tui wurde mit
125.000 euro aus dem basf subventioniert
und wenn man auch noch kfw hilfskredite
mit einbezieht die ja ebenfalls über den
wsf staatlich garantiert werden können
dann sind es sogar
430.000 euro pro t angestellte tausende
von kleinen reisebüros und
reiseveranstaltern hätten mit demselben
recht durch den staat gerettet werden
können sie aber wurden einfach corona
opfer und die sich olaf scholz weder als
finanzminister noch jetzt als kanzler in
irgendeiner form kümmert
ganz im gegenteil in deutschland werden
heute millionen menschen durch
zweijährigen schuldlos diskriminiert
ohne medizinische logik denn auch
geimpfte sind potenziell ansteckend und
sie belegen auch tausende von
intensivbetten eine gesellschaft ist
krank wenn menschen ständig symptomlos
beweisen müssen gesund zu sein oder gar
bei verweigerung des eigenen körpers
gegenüber einer zunehmend wirkungslosen
und unsicheren neuen imz methodik
überall ausgesperrt werden die afg
erklärt sich hier auch heute mal wieder
solidarisch mit millionen von menschen
in deutschland die täglich zu unrecht in
deutschland dieses unrecht und dieses
kritik rimini rung erfahren wir erleben
seit märz 2020 eine politisch gemacht
der eskalation aus dem statistisch hat
bei definierten und durch prämien für
bettenabbau noch beförderten
gesundheitsnotstand würde über
faktischen impfzwang ein rechts notstand
dann über lockt uns ein wirtschafts
notstand und eben schließlich ein
haushaltsnotstand wir müssen raus aus
dieser dauerschleife beenden sie die
vollständig gescheitert maßnahmen gegen
korona und der haushalt und die
wirtschaft werden sich von alleine
berappeln zur konstruktion des wsf genau
wie der finanzkrise vor 10 jahren hören
wir auch heute wieder den spruch es sind
doch bloß garantie genau wie damals das
war übrigens damals vor genau zehn
jahren der titel eines artikels den ich
damals zur ersten griechenland-rettung
veröffentlicht hatte die garantien von
heute sind die kredite von morgen die
abschreibungen von übermorgen und am
ende höhere steuern auch heute wieder
ist die garantie konstruktion nur ein
trick zur zeitlichen aufschiebung der
öffentlichen aufregung darüber die durch
garantien verbürgten kredite des wsf
sind teilweise verloren aber das sagen
sie den menschen heute noch nicht auch
lindner wird es nicht sagen der eben
einbruch der gewaltenteilung von der
regierung zur legislative wechselten
die kfw und der wsf werden diese
garantien die abschreibungen werden dann
künftige steuerzahler belasten aber erst
nach der ampel und ausgerechnet mann ist
der satz frau präsidentin der fdp
finanzminister lindner macht mit dieser
verschleierung genau dort weiter wo die
märke groko aufgehört hatte vielen dank
der bundestag diskutiert über hilfen für
die wirtschaft insbesondere für
unternehmen und betriebe die von corona
stark betroffen sind in ihren
aktivitäten
zeitgleich und parallel dazu läuft nach
wie vor der wahlgang für zwei
vizepräsident
beziehungsweise eine vizepräsidentin
da ist ja katrin göring eckardt
angetreten für die grünen und für die
afg michael kaufmann im zweiten wahlgang
schon inzwischen dass wir gesagt läuft
parallel während hier weiter diskutiert
wird über wirtschaftshilfen jetzt von
sven christian kindler für bündnis 90
die grünen
noch lange nicht vorbei die
krankenhäuser geraten an ihre
kapazitätsgrenzen auf normalstation auf
intensivstationen in einigen regionen
deutschland sind sie schon weiter längst
darüber hinaus wir haben gestern in der
anhörung zum infektionsschutzgesetz im
hauptausschuss sommer sehr deutlich
gehört dass die eine neue schwere
variante höchstwahrscheinlich zu
befürchten ist mit der omnicom variante
die im januar in deutschland dann das
regime übernehmen könnte und das zeigt
ja für uns alles ist jetzt notwendig
auch konsequente maßnahmen gegen diese
pandemie zu ergreifen das ist jetzt
unsere aufgabe hier im deutschen
bundestag
und viele von uns hier im haus ist sehr
bewusst dass
härtere maßnahmen kontakt beschränkung
reisebeschränkungen untersagen von
veranstaltungen auch regional loch da
uns das angesichts der schweren vierten
welle und der blick von variante vor der
tür dass das einerseits jetzt
konsequente maßnahmen braucht aber
andererseits wissen wir auch dass es
natürlich kurzfristig negative deutlich
negative wirtschaftliche folgen auch für
betroffene branchen- und betroffene
betriebe hat es in der anhörung gestern
auch noch mal deutlich klar geworden
dass es mittelfristig ökonomisch für
unsere wirtschaft deutlich besser und
sinnvoller ist die panierten griff zu
kriegen als die laufen zu lassen das
zeigen alle empirischen erkenntnisse
weltweit aber kurzfristig haben wir
negative wirtschaftliche effekte und die
müssen wir natürlich so weit wie es geht
eben auch für betriebe und betroffene
branche auch verhindern dass machen wir
heute hier und das ist sehr wichtig für
uns
und deswegen
beraten wir in der koalition dass sie
die bestehenden breiten
wirtschaftshilfen auch verlängern und
konkret jetzt auch diskutieren wir heute
die verlängerung des wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds bis mitte des
nächsten jahres bis sommer 22 wir haben
als fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen der
einrichtung dieses fonds auch schon
zugestimmt weil es insbesondere für
mittelständische und große unternehmen
eine hilfe braucht die durch harte
maßnahmen betroffen sind oder
eingeschränkt sind aber auch die durch
internationale verwerfungen auf den
märkten auch massive beeinträchtigungen
haben deswegen sinnvoll dass wir jetzt
hier in der ampelkoalition entwurf auf
den weg gebracht haben ich danke auch
nochmal otto frick und es wurde für die
konstruktiven beratungen das zeigt auch
das parlament des handlungsfähig in
zeiten wo auch die exekutive der neuen
regierung noch nicht im amt ist deswegen
sage ich nur ich bitte sie darum dieser
verlängerung auch dann der zweiten
dritten lesung wenn sie kommt auch dann
zuzustimmen
ich will aber auch noch einmal sehr
deutlich sagen die bisherigen regeln zum
wird stabilisierungsfonds geld noch
weiterhin
wer jetzt auch in zum wie solidarität
des staates erwartet auch von uns allen
von bürgerinnen und bürgern zur
bewältigung wirtschaftlicher krisen da
muss auch dann sich an die regeln die im
parlament aufgestellt wurde im haus aus
ein bisschen die auch halten der wird
sich ein beziehungs frauen die nicht
exklusiv nicht zur absicherung von boni
für top manager und vorstände und er
dient auch explizit nicht zur
absicherung von dividendenzahlungen
aktionäre mit steuergeld auch werden wir
im haus ist auch schon fundament sehr
genau achten dass das nicht der fall ist
und ich würde mir auch wünschen dass das
auch für andere krisen absichern
maßnahmen geht wo wir auch konkret
steuergeld einsetzen und ich werde mal
was sagen zur verteilung der
eigentümerseite der wsf muss auch der
lender of last resort der
wirtschaftshilfe bleiben als letzte
mittel das wir einsetzen bei den
wirtschaftshilfen und wir haben es ja
oft erlebt in krisen dass am ende in
wirtschaftlichen krisen das ohr wenn er
die allgemeinheit für wirtschaftliche
risiken zahlt und das vermögen privater
eigentümer dann ohne eigenleistung
abgesichert wird das darf nicht der fall
sein ich erwarte dass die unternehmen
wenn sie unter den schutzschirm auch
gehen auch klar relevante beiträge der
eigentümer dann auch leisten das ist
unsere anforderungen
und wir werden noch sehr genau darauf
achten dass die ökologischen und
klimapolitischen ziele der europäischen
union die die grundlage für die
genehmigung der europäischen kommission
waren für den wsf dass die auch bei der
beantragung und bei der entscheidung
auch berücksichtigung finden es gegen
die sehr pandemie um eine stabilisierung
der wirtschaft ja aber das darf kein
fossilen login bedeuten wir müssen eine
stabilisierung der wirtschaft willkommen
wir müssen auf eine transformation der
wirtschaft hin bekommen und die
einhaltung der einzug von fünf grad
grenze mit den klimapolitischen der
europäischen union das ist grundlage für
alle entscheidungen
kinder
sven christian kindler für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen und der hat zu
beginn seines redebeitrags den
hauptausschuss erwähnt also die das
gremium in dem moment noch eine vorlagen
die hier im plenum dann diskutiert
werden besprochen und erörtert und nach
beraten werden das wird sich nächste
woche mittwoch ändern denn dann werden
die regulären ausschüsse eingesetzt
werden victor perli ist am pult für die
fraktion die linke
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren es ist richtig in dieser
schwierigen krise alles dafür zu tun
wenn der teig so weiter zu verhindern es
hat die linke immer unterstützt es ist
auch richtig jetzt diese hilfen zu
verlängern aber wir kritisieren dass die
neue koalition die fehler in dem alten
gesetz nicht korrigiert damit habe ich
auch erlebt dass die staatlichen hilfen
die beschäftigten nicht abgesichert
haben für uns linke ist klar wenn
konzerne mit milliarden gerettet werden
dann darf es keine entlassungen und dann
darf es kein lohndumping geben
und wir können wir können auch nicht
akzeptieren dass wir diese konzerne ihr
geld in steueroasen
verschwindenlassen öffentliches geld
muss öffentlichen interessen dienen
das beispiel lufthansa
verdeutlicht das problem die lufthansa
wurde gerettet aber 30.000 menschen
wurden entlassen über 30.000 menschen
die bundesregierung wurde durch die
beteiligung durch diese staatshilfe zum
größten eigentümer aber anstatt um die
jobs zu kämpfen olaf scholz und haben
peter altmaier geschwiegen das darf auf
gar keinen fall studie machen und
deswegen muss das gesetz geändert werden
und wir wundern uns schon dass sich spd
und grüne nicht dafür einsetzen die spd
damals gesagt mit cdu/csu es nicht mehr
drin die grünen haben mit uns zusammen
position gekämpft für ein besseres
gesetz und jetzt sind sie an der
regierung und nicht ein weiter so ohne
änderungen gesetz vor was für eine
enttäuschung
meine damen und herren mit öffentlichem
geld müssen öffentliche interessen
gesichert werden das gilt auch für die
korona impfstoffe eine pandemie kann
wohl weltweit besiegt werden deshalb
muss die neue bundesregierung
schleunigst die blockade beenden zur
freigabe der patente es muss aufhören
die lobbytätigkeit für die
pharmaindustrie geben sie endlich die
patente frei das werden sie von uns
heute und in zukunft noch sehr häufig
hören vielen dank
victor perli war das für die
linksfraktion und nächster redner am
pult ist einer von insgesamt 13 mit dem
nachnamen müller in diesem fall ist es
carsten müller aus der unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren die pandemie ist noch
nicht besiegt und wir haben gestern von
einigen regierungsmitgliedern hören
können das zum bekämpfen der pandemie
auch rote linien überschritten werden
wir haben allerdings das gehört zur
wahrheit in den letzten wochen ebenfalls
in diesem hause lernen müssen dass
einige gelbe linien nicht überschritten
werden und wir als union glauben dass
wir alles das was hilfreich erforderlich
sinnvoll und wirtschaftlich vertretbar
ist getan werden ist meine damen und
herren aus diesem grund ist die
verlängerung des stabilisierungsfonds
gesetzes und die verlängerung das und
die zustimmung zum wirtschaftlich
gesinnungs beschleunigungs gesetzes und
die verlängerung des lebens bis zum 30
juni 20 22 aus unserer sicht
grundsätzlich erforderlich und richtig
die europäische kommission das ist eben
angesprochen worden sieht das ähnlich
und stimmt der verlängerung der
entsprechenden maßnahmen insofern zu
allerdings meine damen und herren das
will ich noch mal mit blick auf den
redner der spd fraktion sagen er hat
sich dann zum schluss seiner rede etwas
korrigiert dieses dieser wsf ist kein
neues instrument sondern tatsächlich
wiesen im zweiten teil ihrer rede gesagt
haben ein instrument aus dem märz 2020
ganz wesentlich von der union initiiert
warum damals diese maßnahme weil uns der
erhalt von unternehmen und von
arbeitsplätzen und wirtschaftskraft
wichtig ist und ich finde dass ich
richtig dass durchaus deutlich an die
weiteren oppositionsfraktion ich finde
das nicht okay dass sie versuchen
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
abhängig davon wer der arbeitgeber es
hier im bundestag gegeneinander
auszuspielen
meine damen und herren
wir haben angelehnt an das
finanzmarktstabilisierungsfonds aus dem
jahr 2008 diesen fonds zu verstärken der
wirtschaft ins leben gerufen das ist
wichtig wie gesagt um auch
unverschuldete insolvenzen dieser
schwierigen zeit zu verhindern ich will
allerdings auf einen wichtigen punkt aus
sicht der union noch einmal hinweisen
sie haben es bedauerlicherweise bei dem
antrag auch in ihren begründungen
vollkommen unterlassen darauf
hinzuweisen der kollege fricke hatte das
mit einem halbsatz versucht abzutun dass
wir jetzt doch eine leichte änderung der
spielregeln bekommen sie lassen nämlich
dem geltungszeitraum und die möglichkeit
entsprechende anträge zu stellen
zeitlich auseinander fallen und weil es
so ist dass diese maßnahmen die wir
heute verlängern wollen im wesentlichen
auf liquiditätsengpässe abzielen und
diese kurzfristig eintreten bitte ich
sie ich fordere sie regelrecht auf zu
überprüfen und das ist der wunsch der
union die antragsfrist nicht bereits am
30 04 enden zu lassen sie führen mit 2
ungedeckte monate aus und wir sehr
geehrte kollege fricke sind sehr dafür
dass wir den programm zeitraum und den
zeitraum zur erstellung entsprechender
anträge kongruent ausgestaltet und
deswegen wie in der vergangenheit auf
den selben tag fallen lassen sie sollten
das beraten wir werden dem grundsätzlich
zustimmen haben aber diese dringende
änderung anderen vielen dank für
aufmerksamkeit
carsten müller aus der unionsfraktion in
der debatte in einer ersten beratung zum
wirtschafts
stabilisierungs beschleunigungsgesetz
wenn man es ganz langsam liest versteht
man auch dieses lange wort monstrum und
kassen oder bei der drittletzte redner
jetzt also der zweitletzte bernd
westphal für die spd fraktion in der
letzten legislaturperiode wirtschafts
und energiepolitischer sprecher
wir haben heute mit dem thema wirtschaft
stabilisierungsfonds ein baustein dessen
was wir auf den weg gebracht haben
natürlich lieber kollege müller aus der
letzten regierung weil die pandemie ja
schon länger dauert wieder alle wissen
und deshalb war es richtig
dass wir in der großen koalition anfang
2020 gezeigt haben dass wir einen
handlungsfähigen staat haben dass wir
mit den überbrückungshilfen mit den
soforthilfen mit dem neustart hilfe und
natürlich auch mit dem instrument
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds
deutlich gezeigt haben dass wir damit
nicht nur eine zuschauerrolle haben
sondern mit einem aktiven staat
handlungsfähig sind die ökonomische
basis in unserem land zu sichern und vor
allen dingen auch ein signal an
arbeitsplätze zu geben meine damen und
herren
jetzt geht es darum dieses vertrauen
diese sicherheit in politisches handeln
zu verlängern weil wir noch nicht durch
sind durch die pandemie deshalb gilt es
natürlich zuerst alles dafür zu tun
unser gesundheitssystem zu stabilisieren
den menschen mit impfen mit unserem
gesundheitssystem sicherheit zu geben
dass wir diese gefährdung für die
gesundheit durchschreiten aber das was
nicht geht der bürger von fdp will ich
ganz genau sagen sie stellen sich
hierhin sie spalten sie hetzen sind
unsolidarisch das ist das was wir im
moment nicht brauchen nicht als argument
alles dafür tun dass sie die
verantwortung über dieses land kriegen
wir haben für die wirtschaftshilfen hohe
anerkennung gekriegt nicht nur von den
wirtschaftsinstituten in deutschland
sondern weltweit das volumen was wir in
der ausgestaltung der einzelnen
maßnahmen hatten hat anerkennung
gefunden und auch wirkung gezeigt wir
haben es geschafft in der krise eine
brücke zu bauen unternehmen zu
stabilisieren und der wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds hat natürlich mit
einem großen volumen zu anfang wo wir
nicht wussten wo die reise hingeht dafür
gesorgt dass dieses vertrauen bestehen
und deshalb passen wir das jetzt an
meine vorredner haben einiges davon
gesagt und vor allen dingen haben wir
auch dafür gesorgt dass das europa
kompatibel ist das ist im europäischen
rahmen der ball für rechtlich möglich
dieses instrument zu verlängern und
deshalb werden wir vor allen dingen
sicherheit dafür geben ein signal zu
setzen dass mit dieser stabilisierung
die wirtschaft auch durch diese krise
kommt und ich greife das auch gerne auf
was der kollege fricke gesagt hat wir
haben eine
bewältigung der krise aber auch darauf
abzuheben inwieweit sich unternehmen
weiterentwickeln in der transformation
im wandel zu einer klimaneutralen
produktion und deshalb ist es ja
vielleicht ratsam zu gucken welche
instrumente die wir dafür nehmen könnt
aufbaut aus dem was wir haben mit dem
wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds ein
transformations- fonds zu entwickeln der
unternehmen genau diese leitplanken
ermöglicht für die großen investitionen
die notwendig sind und deshalb freue
mich freue ich mich auf die beratungen
die wir im wirtschaftsausschuss und dem
finanzausschuss ja dazu haben und
deshalb auch kollege müller sind ja
durchaus anregungen was die fristen und
bearbeitung angeht diese debatten dann
genau in dem parlament in den
ausschüssen notwendig wir werden weiter
dafür sorgen dass wir die wirtschafts
und finanzpolitischen engagement weiter
verstärken um genau diesen
handlungsfähigen staat diese sicherheit
zu organisieren wir haben mit olaf
scholz ein bundeskanzler der jetzt mit
viel kompetenz und erfahrung den
krisenstab in cannes eingerichtet hat
wir werden das weiter verfolgen wie sich
diese krise entwickelt und dadurch alles
dafür tun dass wir das schnell
rauskommen aber ich will auch sagen zum
schluss meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren die bürgerinnen und bürger alle
können einen beitrag dazu leisten und
deshalb kann ich dazu aufrufen nehmen
sie die impf angebote wahr hören sie
nicht auf scharlatane in diesem land
sorgen sie dafür dass sie für sich und
für die allgemeinheit für den
gesundheitsschutz sorgen mit einer
impfung und dann werden wir relativ
schnell den weg damit eben aus dieser
pandemie heraus herzlichen dank und
bernd westphal war das für die spd
fraktion der vorletzte redner in einer
debatte die sich mit wirtschafts
höfliche unternehmen befasst die
aufgrund der
pandemie in eine schieflage oder größere
schwierigkeiten geraten sind florian
oßner aus der unionsfraktion
klammer aufzug lama zuletzt
wir lassen unsere unternehmen in dieser
pandemie nicht im stich deshalb ist es
völlig richtig dass wir
unterstützungsleistungen in unserem land
aus dem stabilisierungsfonds gesetz bis
zum 30 juni 20 22 verlängern wir müssen
alles ja wirklich alles dafür tun unsere
gesunden unternehmen zu schützen
arbeitsplätze zu sichern und die
substanz unserer wirtschaft in
deutschland zu erhalten dafür steht die
parteien familie aus csu und cdu
bei dem er bei dem gesamtvolumen von 50
milliarden euro ist auch unbedingt
sicher zu stellen dass die genutzte
kreditermächtigung in abzug gebracht
wird aber nichtsdestotrotz werden wir in
den nächsten vier jahren die links gelbe
regierungskoalition insbesondere bei
haushalts- und fiskalpolitischen fragen
konstruktiv kritisch begleiten die von
der fdp immer wieder propagierte service
opposition werden wir zur smart
opposition also mit klugen konzepten
weiterentwickeln alles was bislang im
koalitionsvertrag zu lesen war gab
leider nicht zu erkennen wie die neue
bundesregierung ihre vielen neuen
ausgabe wünsche finanzieren möchte
haushaltspolitik meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen darf am ende
kein wunschkonzert sein
die die ampel scheint einseitig auf
umverteilung gestellt zu sein und
vergisst dass nur das verteilt werden
kann was vorher auch erwirtschaftet
wurde die ampel scheint auf
vergemeinschaftung von schulden in
europa besteht zu sein und die ampel
scheint auf einen haushaltspolitischen
schlendrian mit buchungstricks gestellt
zu sein die haben ende jeden bürger in
deutschland die rechnung präsentiert wir
als cdu und csu möchten keine
verschuldung auf kosten zukünftiger
generationen das ist der unterschied
liebe neue bundesregierung
abschließend abschließend präsidenten
möchte ich der links gelben ampel eine
gute in der stadt wünschen am ende muss
es aber auch gut für deutschland sein
wir passen gut auf herzliches vergelt's
gott fürs zuhören florian oßner war das
aus der unionsfraktion so ganz einig ist
man sich in der unionsfraktion offenbar
noch nicht wenn man das vergleicht mit
dem er ein beitrag den wir zu beginn
dieser debatte von andreas jung gehört
haben der gesagt hat vorlagen nicht
danach bewerten woher sie kommen sondern
danach was drinsteht klang jetzt dass
ein kleines bisschen anders